hi I'm Adam ray and I'm Jessie Mae and
welcome to assume the position this is a
show takes a look at a sexy topic yeah
yeah sex we've all had it I mean well
maybe you have maybe you have even if
you haven't you've heard of it maybe you
need pills to get it done her blow-up
doll I know know my name
okay it was one time it was a dare and I
don't regret it facts we still keep in
touch so a lot of touch I know what
happens on Fridays over at the house
whole let's get going we're gonna look
in the position of the daybook check out
some positions and see if we can guess
the names yeah gonna cover it up like
this my mom's watching well now she's
definitely oh boy oh wow um circa oh
yeah the backwards hammock the hot dog
press the the recess teacher wow you're
good at this yeah I'd like to order
number two please you know when you're
like screaming what's the thing that
cheerleaders use the nothing mega feat
aggressive yeah but the big thing when
you push the button what it is use it
whoa oh boy he looks like he's screaming
like the high school announcement into
her anus guys we ran out of Turkey slot
today Jared Simmons please come to the
principal's office the marriage saver
you think this would save them the 68 I
don't understand do you understand I've
always joked about other number
positions yeah saying like like 69 is
pretty classic yeah there's like a 29
which is just
the back button but what we're in West
Hollywood up - the dirgo oh wow that's a
stretch
tooth dead the stop drop and roll into
me the Sharon Sharon Bashar Bashar yeah
this is how she reflects it would be
great if you just got that famous for
like like you know there's like I dunno
I've seen there's that so you like
lasagna what this is this is why it's
dangerous to be a woman just Wolfgang
Puck John yeah today's guests don't
assume the position is a very dear
friend of ours a hilarious comedian with
showtime specials called daddy issues
and fun-sized you've also seen him on
Netflix's the degenerates he co-hosts a
podcast with me called about last night
and he met his wife on a threesome app
give it up for the one and only Brad
Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right now Brad Williams
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Ramar you see when I have Popeye thanks
for giving me a pool oh it's a mug okay
I'm sorry I mean I wasn't quite sure I
was like oh it's a swimming pool Brad
float that's a good spin off yeah Brad
you've uh it's safe to save had sex
before yeah once it was good no I know
yeah yeah yeah speaking of once yeah do
you remember that very first time oh
yeah I I remember the very first time
because I I lost my virginity and very
strange way eh was with another little
person right there
magical does it weigh if it doesn't have
to be I mean it was brought up in the
last council meeting
but yeah the guy with the very long
beard said so let it be said it's a lot
of fun so you have to yeah well it's
it's a dwarf so it's just dull yeah it's
a shortened version yeah uh I lost my
virginity to a lovely dwarf woman that I
had been dating for two years I was
twenty years old so a little late yeah
yeah a little late I was waiting and not
by my choice yeah I I lost my virginity
to a dwarf woman who was very religious
so she made us or she made me pray right
before we banged so yeah so like she
finally called me she was living in San
Francisco I was living in Los Angeles
she called me and she's like hey parents
are going away for the weekend we've
been dating for two years I think it's
time and I'm like [ __ ] yeah and I got
the 20 year old yeah yeah that drove up
there was like doing this [ __ ]
and then I get the condoms I get
everything we light some candles cuz I'm
a gentleman we're about to do the thing
right we were like making out and we're
naked we're like all this sex is gonna
happen that's what I said in my head
very cool and better than saying it out
loud yeah and then she stops and she
goes hey before we do this I think III
think we should pray I was like what
that's rude she didn't tell you before
yeah so I with my 20 year old virgin
boner still raging because 20
everybody's not gonna do it never done
anything before with it so I had to sit
down and like with her also naked like
improvise a prayer to God thing like hey
we've been together for like two years
so we're not going to hell if we [ __ ]
right like yeah that was that was asking
him to bless the very awkward sex we
were about to have do you remember the
exact prayer or was it just no it was
basically a long lines of here Lord we
know that we're supposed to wait but
we've been together for two years we
feel we have a very strong relationship
and we we do this not to spite you but
to honor you for yeah because you know
you've never seen two dwarves Bobby this
is for you you know you're watching
because you're everywhere yeah and then
and then we did it and then within a
month we were broken up so yeah that was
uh obviously we were we waited for the
right time there's a lot of sex stories
out there Brad yeah and yours being one
of them there's a lot of one's making
headlines so we thought we'd read them
get some perspectives and discuss as a
group in a segment we call nympho news
today college doesn't go down on his
wife here's why he said a woman should
praise the man the king if you holdin it
down for your woman I feel the woman
should praise and a man should praise
the Queen but you know my way of
praising is called ha ha how was dinner
you like the house you women you like
all them clothes you gettin I'm taking
care of your family my family I'm
putting in the work
wait okay well first of all I have seen
DJ Khaled's performance he's not working
uh he brings out a lot of other people
they work he's like yo Meek Mill and
then Meek Mill runs that comes out does
a great rap and then College in the back
trying to burn as few calories as
possible and also with how fat that guy
is you think he would be eating more but
he doesn't so a pan so apparently when
he says another one that just applies to
cake
our next nympho news a Florida woman was
shot after performing a sexual act on a
suspected gunman in exchange for $5 in
Pringles because you know that once you
you can't stop suckin the Pringles you
didn't even have to say a Florida woman
you couldn't just read the story we'd be
like so in Florida this happened so wait
was he holding her hostage or what were
what was this in exchange at a Shell
station at a Shell station after he
demanded his money back uh and shot her
in the shoulder he wanted his money won
$5 Wow
first of all that's like the Walmart of
[ __ ] right there
five bucks you mad cuz like I've been
I've been to Vegas I
women of the night come on to me not in
offer stuff I've never talked him down
to five bucks that's a bargain
yeah like I was like whoa what would $50
get me there like a hug you know I'm
like all right so that I don't I can't
come from a hug anymore uh like for me
like what the value of my vagina would
be like the flavor of Pringles would
probably have to be taken into
consideration
yeah like wow look Caitlin what kind of
room yeah would you do it for sour cream
and onion oh yeah okay Michelle ass my
husband doesn't turn me on anymore
how can reignite the fire after 36 years
of marriage [ __ ] old do it no you don't
know one of nuts when I do bangs you and
front in front of your husband do that
[ __ ] 36 years he'll be really inspired
36 years does seem like an amount of
time where you you have to pull out all
the stops try some stuff you know maybe
a little roleplay dream you try to
incorporate some food maybe do some
blindfolds some toys yeah bust some [ __ ]
up maybe that doesn't work if that
doesn't work call Brad over call me do
it no you sure open a sexy outfit yeah
I've done it before
what okay I'm Worf gigolos happy wharf
gigolo holy can we find that that is
your price and what would you think
legitimately would be your wife's price
five dollars five dollars in a can of
Pringles in our final segment we've got
a bunch of sexual positions written down
in this mug that we have not seen and
Brad is going to pull one out and then
try to draw what he thinks that position
looks like in a game we call position
area
that's like just got an Indian burn okay
so we're gonna put 60 seconds on the
clock we'll use this little fun guy for
time and we're gonna yell out our
guesses alright and don't [ __ ] this up
will not [ __ ] this up on your mark get
set
drop high kick whoa D ninja okay
the the catapult close yeah it's part of
the same this realm should moments I'm
not proud to live in this country and
putt-putt close I'm gonna draw one more
an alternate version of this okay
Leo what is it the shot Busch shock put
the javelin the high kick NFL starting
line that's his penis that's a penis
yeah the teeny teeny teeny teeny what is
that dangling off him like oh my god
ground zero like I'm gonna change after
where when you leave prison Oh misty
shades are great all right imagine Bosh
doing this yeah yeah yeah it actually
was good we're just gonna do you were
close with [ __ ] punt because punt is a
term from football and the actual name
of the position I was trying to draw is
the Heisman so yeah so he's trying to
like so that's like some advanced
fingering going on right there oh yeah
yeah that's what he's doing
your Heisman pose
is very anti-semitic yeah well you gave
it a valiant effort bread over there
send you home empty-handed so we are
giving you a $10 gift card to Jamba
Juice yeah I get a razzmatazz get
whatever you want do you want me to draw
what I think the Rasmus head see one
more time give it up for our guest where
they can find you and see you and all
that yeah go to my website Brad Williams
comedy comm that's got all my tour dates
there on Twitter that funny bread on
instagram at Bravo's comic and subscribe
to my podcast that I do with this
Tuesday big it is carrying the pad carry
the fact the about last night podcast
subscribe we have a lot of great
fantastic guests those are just amazed
nipples sweet your questions you get
some advice first segment that we call
bad vice using hashtag bad vice or email
us at ATP at all things comedy dot-com
with your questions concerns and we'll
answer them on the show until then join
us next week when we assume the position
listen carefully sir
when I get my daughter on the show
[Music]
you